[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the journalist and author yasmin alibi
brown and the editor of politico's
london playbook alex wickham good
evening to both of you and uh you're
both going to be with us until midnight
aren't you so i'll be talking to you in
just a moment but first let's take a
look then at what's on those front pages
and the times is leading with the
chancellor's remarks that boost the jabs
will prevent another lockdown
the guardian have the headline uk
sleepwalking into winter of covert chaos
unions worn on the front of the
financial times they report on downing
street recalling emily lawson to run
england's covid19 vaccine program
the mirror leads with a picture of alec
baldwin after a prop gun he fired killed
a crew member on a film set
and the star also go with that story on
their front page
the foreign secretary says that we can't
be dependent on china according to the
telegraph
why did palace cover up the truth on the
queen the daily mail continues to report
on the story of the queen spending a
night in hospital earlier this week
so let's talk through some of those
front pages now with yasmin alibi brown
and alex wickham a proper welcome to
both of you and you've picked out the
times front page first of all um alex
this goes with
the boost the jab program that the
government is trying to really
switch up a notch
with a new uh
nationwide program to try to get people
to come forward the headline is boost
the jabs will prevent lockdown says
sunak we're getting a really clear idea
of the government's position now aren't
we
yeah and you know we may say well we've
been here before haven't we this time
last year boris johnson told us all
there's not going to be another lockdown
christmas will be fine he was telling
that us that right up until christmas
and of course then he u-turned and and
we were back into lockdown all the rest
of it well this is the government saying
once again there's not going to be a
lockdown but i do think this time they
mean it they they do seem to really
genuinely believe now that the vaccine
is the game changer that there is a
level of protection in the country that
means whatever happens the deaths are
never going to reach the level that they
did last time round but there is
increasing worry in downing street
tonight that the booster program which
is so crucial in giving that protection
to people after six months of their
after their second dose
isn't working fast enough and people
aren't coming forward in the numbers
required it's starting to tick up this
week we've seen some really positive
numbers last couple of days well over
200 000 in the lot each of the last two
days getting their booster but that
number really needs to ramp up as
quickly as possible with cases as high
as they are over 50 000 a day it's in
the papers this week that a million
people had covered are getting covered
basically per week which is uh pretty
shocking numbers to be honest i mean
that's as that's as bad as it gets so
that booster program rishi sunak saying
is the way to prevent lockdown ever
happening again and people just need to
go out and get it well yes that's right
and the numbers are high but yasmin the
prime minister today was saying we
always thought that numbers would go
high but he didn't see any reason why
title restrictions might be needed at
the moment but
how likely do you think that the booster
program will go well i mean that the
original vaccination program went
extremely well didn't it are you
confident that people will come forward
and the vaccinations will be there
when they need them
well i mean i had my booster uh jab this
week which is very good
i think it is ridiculous for rishi sunak
or boris johnson
to be the norwals in this situation it
is they keep saying they're following
the science and listening to the medics
and the majority of
people in those professions are
incredibly worried the vaccination
program has been fantastically well
coordinated i've just come back from
france
where i never saw a single person in
paris without a mask or not keeping to
the social distancing law you went to
every restaurant
you had to follow strict guidelines
we gave all that up and now rishi thinks
that
solely using booster jabs or vaccination
as a way
out of this is is quite dangerous
thinking a thousand people
uh are dying a month
yeah now if it was if this was tb how
would the nation react
and the rates of infection as as we've
just heard are incredibly high so we
need a much more coordinated um effort
and don't don't shut off
avenues which might be needed
i wish politicians had learned from the
last time around
that
you know this disease is not as easily
controlled as they seem to think it is
they don't seem to have learnt anything
do you think that's right alex or will
they say we've just had really good uh
research that shows that the booster jab
is
seems to be very effective if people do
come forward
do you think they're concerned that
there would be some resistance to
working at home again or wearing masks
or some of those elements of plan b
that's definitely part of it and the
chancellor richie sunak says in the
times uh tomorrow that
that he is prioritizing the economy and
the government is very clearly
prioritizing the economy over
um
over the health situation now which is
not you know what they said they were
at least what they would argue they were
doing um earlier on in the pandemic and
that sort of represents a shift that
they believe is has happened with the
british public and there is certainly
some polling that does appear to show um
attitudes have shifted away from you
know being very pro lockdown very pro
restrictions happy to be compliant with
the government rules as britons were um
earlier on in the pandemic towards
actually no we want to go out there now
and
live on normal lives again uh post the
vaccine roll out and as yasmin says you
know in europe
people much more compliant with those
sort of coronavirus easy coronavirus
measures like masks and that's not
really happening masks are still
required um on the tube and you go on
the tube and and very few people are
wearing masks and and there is definite
there has definitely been a sort of
drop-off i think in uh in just general
uh keenness to to do some of these basic
measures among brits and that's
definitely reflected in the government
okay yeah and jasmine i can see you want
to come in there
just to say respond to what alex was
saying which was interesting
uh because it was unexpected was this
poll that the times carried out that's
76
now
back mask wearing and 69
would back return
in working from home which really
surprised him because i think alex is
right that the attitudes had shifted so
this poll was quite interesting in the
times
yeah interesting we'll have to check
that one out let's move on though to the
ft because they bring in a different
element as well don't they they've said
that number 10 is recalling a
they call it a jabs chief this is emily
lawson isn't it to the front line
so does this give us another indication
that they're really going hell for
leather with with boosters
yeah i think so and emily emily lawson
not one of the most high-profile uh
officials in the government she was
originally sort of one of the most
senior people in charge of the vaccine
campaign last time around boris johnson
was so happy with her work that he when
covid was going a bit better earlier in
the year he he whistler often took her
to be in charge of his delivery unit in
number 10 which was sort of everything
else the government's doing in in the
conservative manifesto trying to get
some of that started uh it's a sign of
the times and how things are going that
she's had to be taken aback away from
that and put back on vaccines again so
that is definitely a sign that firstly
number 10 are worried about the
situation and worried that the booster
campaign isn't doing the job yet but
also that they want to be seen to be
doing something there's been a flurry of
press releases uh today and yesterday
and
we saw sanji javid's press conference
this week despite you know previously
being weeks without a coronavirus press
conference there's definitely a little
bit of concern in number 10 on the sort
of common side of things that they they
definitely definitely need to be seen to
be acting because what they're not doing
is what some of the scientists want well
there was a sage paper uh today from out
today from the government scientists
saying that the government needs to
really prepare to move to plan b to
bring back some of those measures like
mandatory mask wearing and covet
certification well the government very
clearly isn't isn't there yet it doesn't
want to do that yet it's arguably not
following the science some may say but
what it does want to be doing is
reassuring the public and being seen
that it is doing something and
getting on top of this okay let's move
on to one of the other stories making
the front pages and the telegraph goes
its own way they are quoting liz trust
the new foreign secretary new-ish
foreign secretary um and the headline
they've gone with is her saying we can't
be dependent on china so talk us through
this jasmine
so what i mean it's quite it's a very
interesting um intervention if if
accurately uh reported
that trusts
it it isn't just about dependency
um
i think this is a real challenge to
china
because it is one of the more growing
superpowers one cannot deny it
uh and and globally so
um and this i think she's kind of
drawing a line here saying you know
we're watching you
we are not going to become dependent on
you
uh i mean there's been a very long
period of
manufacturing in china for that
businesses have
been dependent on here particularly the
retail sector particularly fashion and
all that so i think this is bigger than
just foreign um
affairs she was the trade secretary um
and sometimes i think she you know
there's no depth to the way she's
thinking but this seems to me a very
interesting and
um
an
interesting maneuver
and and and i think in some ways quite
right actually and because china is
becoming overbearing now in world
politics sorry to cut in yes men um this
is an interview isn't it that this trust
has given the telegraph alex and what do
you make of the timing of it as well
given that we've got cop 26 looming
china the hope is that china will
improve its commitments as far as
climate change is concerned there's also
talk of nuclear power stations in this
country to try to go greener china could
have been involved potentially in that
what do you make of the timing of this
it's fascinating isn't it i mean by all
accounts the run into cop which is just
a few days away now eight or nine days
away is not going very well for the
government uh you know president xi chi
of china is not is not coming um it
doesn't it doesn't look like there's
gonna be that big incredible
world-leading agreement uh led by boris
johnson to save the planet from climate
change that doesn't appear to be on the
cards expectations are set very low the
government needed china on board i was
speaking to one member of the government
the other day who said the worst thing
that could have possibly happened to the
world was coronavirus originating in
china setting off this sort of chain of
events that has turned china away from
the international community it's seen
joe biden kind of openly speculate that
the on the wuhan lab theory it's seen
politicians like liz trust today the
british foreign secretary you know
taking quite a hard line against china
and from a point of view of climate
change regardless of
all the other important issues related
to china on on the economy and human
rights and all the rest of it but race
to climate change the world needs china
on board and that clearly isn't
happening at the moment okay we'll we'll
uh take a pause at that point um coming
up though these stay there won't you
we've got lots to talk about including a
rishi sunak will put parents at the
heart of his budget next week with 500
million pounds for new family hubs
we'll tell you what that means it's
inside the times coming up
[Music]
you're watching the press preview uh
with me tonight the journalist and
author yazmin alibai brown and the
editor of politico's london playbook
alex wickham so welcome back to both of
you yasmin we're kicking off with a
story inside the times which looks ahead
to the budget which is next week it's on
wednesday so what are they suggesting
might be in it
well
ricky ricky sunak's given quite a long
interview to the times and he's now
saying
that
money's been put aside
for what he calls
family hubs
um half a half a billion pounds to
improve support for children families
mental health issues you know children
from
the age from birth to threes when their
their brains are developing that's when
parenting has to be
is the hardest and actually really a
keystone to the future of that child now
we had these
we had sure start we had an existing
program which did this which actually
brown and blair had put into place and
they were fantastic
places i did a lot of reports on them
they shut them down now they're
reopening them calling them hubs
we need to have continuity you know uh
between governments for very good ideas
um so i'm just kind of yeah good they're
doing this either money isn't going to
be enough and b why shut something down
and start it again
okay well that's interesting i mean they
we don't have the details yet it may be
that they look rather different we'll
have to wait and see on wednesday i
guess and and and find out more detail
i'm going to move this on if that's all
right alex because we haven't got much
time and there is a story on the front
of the mail
about the queen's
visit to hospital earlier this week that
we found about out about last night the
daily mail is saying why did palace
cover up truth on queen there seems to
be a little bit of friction here between
some journalists over how much
information came out what do you make of
it
absolutely it's an interesting one
because i mean the royal sort of core of
journalists are very upset with the
palace's communications team uh tonight
because
they were essentially led to believe
that the queen spent the week at windsor
castle nothing to see here and then the
palace later announced after the fact
actually she spent the night in hospital
so we've got a
very upset uh set of set of royal
journalists who felt that they were
essentially lied to by by the royal uh
household which is you could argue on a
point of view of transparency for the
head of state not great um however
there's also the flip side of the
argument which is that the the
royal family doesn't want to alarm the
whole country
okay i'm going to leave it there because
i think we're going to revisit that
subject at 11 o'clock so i know you're
staying with us to go through some of
the main stories at the top of the 11
but for the moment yasmine and alex
thanks very much indeed